hey guys how's it going happy new year
I'm Justine hi nice to meet you if I
haven't met you already I make videos
here on YouTube if you didn't know that
I wanted to wish you guys all a happy
new year welcome to 2013 you're still
watching to 2012 that's kind of crazy
because it's not 2012 anymore I put
together a playlist of some of my
favorite videos from 2012 and I want to
know from you guys what was your
favorite 2012 memory leave it in the
comments below and as you guys watch my
playlist of 2012 extra you guys leave a
comment and say watching in 2013 I think
that's probably the funniest thing when
I go back and see some of my old videos
give her like watching in 2012 barging
in 2013 it's kind of crazy how much
youtube has changed I mean I started
vlogging before blogging this even a
word in probably like 2004-2005 it's
insane how much it has grown how many
people do it I'm excited to be a part of
the community I'm excited that you guys
watch all of our videos and enjoy all of
our fun content anyway enough of that
make sure you guys check out the
playlist if you're watching on a phone
you will not be able to click this
annotation so i will put a link in the
description and enjoy
you
just when you thought this video was
over it's not over yet thank you guys
for watching my little montage of 2012
like I said before earlier if you were
listening there's a playlist of 2012
videos and the link is in the
description and check it out I love you
guys don't forget to subscribe to this
channel and the rest of my YouTube
channels i know i'm giving you so many
little things to do so i hope that you
can at least accomplished one of them
love you guys see you 2013 just now
you